[Music]
mr
this fall
sick cities
prepare
for two
rebels with a cause
[Applause]
[Music]
phoenix
houston
charleston nashville new york baltimore
the rebels with a cars comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
our technological advancement as a
society has outpaced our system for
handling finite resources because now we
are approaching approaching infinite
resources nailed it
i'm like
really good at this stuff
i run this board i'm the boss what if i
ran for president
i'd be like a super genius president i'd
be like
one of those baby geniuses from the
movie president
i wonder if there's a sale of forever
21.
mug club today only 99 a year 69 dollars
for students veterans or active military
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
hot oh i gotta fix my head once you're
good to be with you it's monday uh and i
am wearing
whoa the old boot
the old boot and uh the specialist who
uh fit me for this boot got really
offended when i said that looks really
dumb
she was like well i didn't design it i
was like oh i was under the impression
that you did
please just give me my uh my bill and
send me on my way
after not helping me
and stephen yes i is would i be all
right look there's a lot to get into
today the inflation reduction act just
passed the senate
good rule of thumb
is when a bill is titled something
it's the opposite of that
so we'll get into that today and how it
affects you and they'll tell you that it
won't affect you and it will affect you
uh also you may not know this but some
palestinian forces killed their own
children it's being reported as the idf
and no fact checks um we also want to
talk about some common sense car reform
here on the show today yeah and uh on
mug club you can go to
littlecredit.comclub
uh with a story on a libertarian who's
financed her campaign uh with only fans
because she couldn't finance it through
black tar heroin
yet it's a live show monday through
thursday if you're not getting
notifications if you're not getting
subscriptions working just uh tune in
here youtube or of course on rumble or
mug club an additional full hour of show
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
it's a live show that's the best way to
find us you won't find us any other way
my question of the day uh where would
you want your money
going if you could pick
instead of the irs in a fire pit
yeah and then some nice veterans could
inhale it yeah yeah that's true then we
wouldn't help them and then we wouldn't
help them with the same money yeah well
you know what let's just cut out the
middle man and give it to the irs yeah
uh so uh you hear them you love them
gerald a is here hi how are you sir i'm
doing fine aside from the foot and you
know him he's the quickest man on his
feet i am on tour with him this fall
phoenix september 16th
arizona federal theater houston
september 17th smart land financial
center at sugarland and then charleston
west virginia october 8th hoyt at the
charleston coliseum then a bunch of
other dates but these are the ones
coming up dave landau ahoy doing well
yeah i'm all right can't complain your
mustache looks thicker i know you said
that i don't know what happened slightly
less pedophilic yeah it's a little more
uh
almost kevin klein
in and out
is it no that's the gay one
i assumed that was the mustache one
that's fair
there's one where he owns a pizza parlor
they want to kill him that's also a gay
one is it well because of what he had in
the computer room all right oh yeah
that's not a just so you know that's not
a real youtube you don't we're not
saying it's a real thing it's just a
ping pong joint now that's all it is
let's
before we move on to the irs because i
want to get into that i don't know if
you guys have seen this this is a woman
who wants the university to police
speech so that she this is if you think
this doesn't matter
it does because unfortunately these
people we view them of course as
psychopaths but
they are seen as uh not only mainstream
but these people uh wield undue
influence and this is something that's
important people say hey comedy you
shouldn't punch down i don't think
you're punching down when you're simply
uh pointing out people who have
influence that flies in the face of
science biology and not to mention the
first amendment so here this woman is uh
complaining about her university not
policing speech so that she doesn't get
misgendered today has been day four of
law school and i spent the morning with
the dean of diversity and inclusion
because i have been misgendered so many
times by the faculty of this university
which claims to stand on progressive
principles and so i go to this dean and
this dean tells me that i need to
exercise grace and patience in the small
things i'm like listen ladies
small thing being misgendered is
distressing i must say
um and i explained to her how hard it is
to try to figure out why people keep
seeing me as a female it's not hard
okay well you can escalate it to the
title nine director i'm like listen the
title nine director was on a webinar
yesterday misgendering people so wish
this lady had no solutions for me on
where to go next and if this hasn't been
psychiatric a learning experience about
how broken our system is and why
policies need to change and how much
bureaucracy there is and how much the
system is set in its ways and why we
need really good attorneys
then i don't know what is
i love how she [ __ ] about bureaucracy
and then says we need more bureaucracy
and attorneys to enforce it i love how
she looks like steve martin and uh not
steve martin but uh martin short playing
alfalfa yes
by the way she's going to regret it
because she's a she's a pretty lady
statistically she'll probably regret the
transition a lot of people do when you
change it no i think she's a cute lady i
mean she's sorry i think she's a cute
she's a she was a cute lady who was
obviously now a man yes but i'm saying
obviously
well i don't know
like she's been on campus for four days
nobody knows who she is or maybe they
don't care to know who she is that's
fine but he sorry he i'm not doing that
on purpose but if you meet it's
impossible to do correct right if you
meet somebody on the street or if you
meet somebody on campus and you have
never met them before do you have to
stop and ask everybody their pronouns or
can you just go oh hey i'm actually he i
know i look female on the outside but i
am male
right be like oh i didn't know i'm sorry
i didn't know that you were a male with
a 28 inch chest and 24 waist i was just
i call everybody a what's-you-woozy
right there you go gets me out of
trouble you dr seuss had to change the
english language let's do that yeah who
by the way was a an actual doctor yes
that has been terrible yeah
really weird diagnosis you have the
figure of a dancer the bad news is that
you have cancer well you're a dick
do you want to make prime right
it hurts enough oh i hear you sobbing
boo hoo i can't help it this is what i
do i'm going to murder you dr seuss
here's some news you might want to
forgive you have three days to live
these pogo sticks out of the room
[Laughter]
my i enjoyed examining your rump
unfortunately i found a malignant lump
playing a trumpet
all right some of your money will be
freeing uh it is seems that your baby's
not breathing oh
zeus well you know what that's often the
landing i don't mean to be a prick but
it looks like you're missing your oh
well and then he's misgendering doctor
yeah that's true full circle he really
wasn't good i'm so glad that we
cancelled his books decades after he
died it was important years later
so uh let's get to this the grinch stole
your genitals yes
instead of candy canes oh it's just
dildos out of that kid's thing
suzy it's brian okay all right good to
see you again all he left in the house
was a miniature butt plug too small for
a mouse
[Laughter]
zeus
we should have known okay
so let's get to the irs here this is the
inflation reduction am i getting that
name right inflation reduction act
because in my head i'm going inflation
bill the bill that causes inflation yes
yes massive uh and i want you to comment
here below tell me what it is that you
know of this bill we've gone through it
i believe it's 78 pages and i'm not
mistaken something like that which is
surprisingly short
considering that it takes over like a
fifth of the economy that's a lot of
money um let's set this up on what uh
the democrats are going to be telling
you but sunday uh president kamala
harris
cast z's vote i'm not going to fall into
that trap again no we're not uh breaking
a 50 50 senate tie and uh this bill was
officially passed the inflation
reduction act so that you don't think
i'm making it up here's a clip the
affirmative and the bill as amended is
passed
i just hope that oversized chair one day
swallows her like pee-wee's playhouse
oh yeah
and the bill is right
if it's like pee-wee's toilet yes
[Laughter]
okay
so what is wrong with this bill there
are actually some things that are good
in this bill yeah but not many and the
good things are actually things that
donald trump had done that were undone
by
former vice president joe biden and he
redid in a less effective way so let me
give you my primary gripes and i
encourage you to go and read this bill
for yourself all references are
available at lotus counter.com i'm just
giving you the synopsis because i know
that most of you aren't going to go read
the bill unless it's a five-page green
new deal don't blame me
this is your fault
uh it's a giant pork barrel never-ending
funnel for democrat interests yeah
and and not only democrat interest but
social justice interest things that
don't even make sense so for example 272
million dollars
goes to native american communities this
is for inflation to reduce inflation
for climate resilience and adaptation
wait including 150 million for tribal
home electrification 10 million for
tribal fish hatcheries uh they're gonna
foam their teepees
i thought these were like the original
solar power they're jerky hanging how
does giving them electricity which has
to come from coal help us any
it they get well you don't understand
this they get a bunch of money yeah yeah
they're happy about it of course they
are but it doesn't all their land has a
little piece of vegas on us yes
wind turbine slot machines boom
272 million dollars to native american
communities for
reducing inflation
yeah okay uh there's two billion dollars
in grants for domestic production of
green vehicles
all right okay i understand that but
again this is not the free market
there's a four thousand dollar credit to
buy a used clean car now to be clear um
there used to be more of a credits and
there still is i think it's seven
thousand dollars for a new green car for
a new electric vehicle okay and that was
capped at 200 once you sold 200 000
tesla sold more than 200 000 vehicles
because theirs didn't suck and so they
were no longer getting that credit
they'll get that credit now one thing in
this bill though is it requires the
lithium hmm the lithium for the
batteries to not be mined in china
so we're gonna get the lithium
africa just so you know just in case
yeah it's not going to come from the
united states because we don't have the
capability because we can't be mining
here no so i'm waiting for that sequel
with dicaprio blood lithium
doesn't roll off the tongue is easy it's
about as about as accurate as his accent
uh
and then um mansion changed his tune now
you know mansion cinema were kind of
hold outs with these giant bills right
and
i i just want you to try and take a
guess before i get to my hunch why do
you think mansion
why do you think mansion changed his
mind all of a sudden
could it be
is it possible
that in the bill to reduce inflation
a ton of money also being promised to
joe manchin to support his mountain vet
well in his backyard the mountain valley
pipeline in his home state of west
virginia next era energy a utility giant
stakeholder in the mountain valley
pipeline is a top donor to both mr
mansion and senator chuck schumer
who negotiated the pipeline side deal
with mr mansion oh
who knew to reduce inflation well yes
and get them more money yes i see but
primarily to uh the to help yeah so can
i oh can i just sim they bought his vote
in a matter of speaking yes you can say
it that way i don't see it that way i
see it i see it as democracy at work
i see it as helping yes
god bless schumer
i love it when you have to buy the votes
for these bills yeah well that's pretty
much how it works you know they stand on
their merits i mean these people
represent you
so let's get to some of the claims
they're making and by claims i mean uh
the lies that they're telling you here's
a claim that they're making okay and
it's obviously in the title uh that the
bill
is going to reduce inflation
here's the truth
incorrect
[Laughter]
it's going to do the exact opposite of
the cliffhanger now you don't need to
take my word for it we can reading
rainbow this there's over 230 economists
who say that it won't reduce inflation
uh by the way when chuck chuck schumer
said they didn't know what they're
talking about when they're his own
intelligence of officials
believe every word that they say when
they're neutral economists who've been
doing this for a very long time who by
the way often lean left and they say
this is going to do nothing it's they
don't know what they're taught these
guys are hacks so let me give you one
example according to a a pen wharton
budget model
the act would very slightly increase
inflation until 2024 and decrease
inflation thereafter well that'll help
you at the pump today yeah
these points
these point estimates are statistically
indistinguishable
from zero
thereby indicating low confidence that
the legislation will have any impact on
inflation i love how they are
statistically indistinguishable from
zero thereby indicating here's what the
economists want to say
are you serious with this [ __ ]
oh my gosh and that was by the way that
analysis was done prior to the marathon
amendment session they had on sunday to
get this bill passed so it could be far
worse now yeah
by the way if you're trying to fix a
problem with the government put too much
money into the system and and helped
fuel inflation if we were going to have
some that's fine but they helped fuel it
a little bit the best way to solve that
is by putting more money into the system
that
caused inflation i also think we should
just start printing more well that's
true just to pay off our foreign debt
right did we stop at some point it's a
good point no we'd never those
presidents never stop good point why
would we ever stop no
we would
if we can't stop you
like when you count your bills only it's
printing that yeah every second of every
day correct
don't take my word for it let's go to
now here's the problem bernie sanders of
course is upset because it's not doing
enough right but he still does have to
lean on the economist to make the first
part of his argument here he is saying
the exact same thing i'm going to take a
moment to say a few words
you need a copy so called inflation
don't brush your hair with a balloon
again
it's so much fun and i say this is a
comb and a hair dryer the same thing
according to the cbo
and other economic organizations who
study this bill
it will in fact have a minimal
impact on inflation now this is them
softening it yeah it actually won't have
a minimal impact it will have a
significant impact
it will increase inflation
let me explain to you why uh the bill's
300 million dollar deficit reduction
which is just it doesn't mean anything
come on sniff test you really think the
democrats care about reducing the debts
yeah nope let's be honest here uh it's
not powered by spending cuts we have a
spending problem we don't have a
taxation problem they want tax hikes
now
half of all the new taxes they'll be
paid by manufacturers and by the way
this idea of increasing the corporate
tax corporations pass pass that on to
you yeah so for example inflation at the
pump inflation beef inflation purchasing
you increase taxes on these corporations
guess what you are now going to have to
pay more for those goods or services
more inflation so let's deal with the
manufacturers first this is not going to
reduce demand this is going to reduce
what what
what economics
supply-side economics it will reduce
supply prices again with the
manufacturing will be passed on to
consumers this happened in case you're
wondering do we have an example of the
60s 70s here's from the wall street
journal
higher taxes on corporate profits and
individual incomes contributed to
inflation by
by depressing investment and
productivity growth let me give an
example 81 was reagan's supply side
oriented tax cuts that brought inflation
down when he came into office 13.5
inflation and three years later 3.2
percent inflation by the way a quick
note about this 300 billion in savings
that they're talking about assume that
some of the sunset provisions in the
affordable care act actually are allowed
to expire which we know in politics
you're never going to let a subsidy go
because if you do the people that voted
for you are going to be pissed off that
they no longer get the free money if
they leave that in which they expect it
will be it'll be
under 100 billion dollars in savings but
you'll not see that on cnn or anywhere
else you'll see 300 billion dollars in
budget deficit reduction because of this
bill
you know what else you won't see on cnn
uh a straight news anchor i was going to
say brian stelton
so yes
i'm saying you won't see him though so
technically it's one less
has he straight
yes well i don't know if he sees his
shadow we're gonna
a few more weeks of living a lie if he
sees his monkey pucks there's four more
weeks of summer geez
leave the light on when you snuggle yeah
that's brunch
and by that i mean i'm going to go to a
bar that you don't need to know about
yes he actually does instagram about
brunch yes hilarious like
nothing better than brunching with this
hot
girl
which is about right after he's had
breakfast yes
and right after breakfast right before
her first lunch between second lunch so
here's uh some another claim that they
make okay
again all references are available at
livegutter.com
they want you to believe that this bill
is only going to affect the richest
americans why they want class warfare
they want you to hate the rich even
though some of your neighbors are rich i
don't hate rich people i don't hate poor
people i despise dishonest people so
congress there you go uh so they say
it'll only affect the richest americans
here's the truth
this bill is actually and it's worse
than accidental it's designed to go
after the middle class it's designed to
go after you
here's why you won't get enough if you
just text the ultra wealthy and the
mechanisms aren't in place that it's a
constant arms race right they can hire
better cpas they can hire lawyers even
if they weren't able to you wouldn't be
able to get the kind of revenue that you
need so it's designed to come after the
middle class middle upper
call upper middle class as well small
business owners let me give to you a
couple examples why so uh this includes
80 billion this bill
in new funding for the irs to help
inflation yes inflation by the way do
you know what their budget is annually
the irs 12.5 billion
they're getting 80 billion dollars in
this bill that's a lot of nuts
we could
why don't we just take that ukrainian
good one that's like six yeah seven
times their annual budget now are you
kidding me yes this is now going to be
known as new irs yes is it true they're
giving them hollow point like they're
they're giving them bullets is that true
yeah they're arming them they are arming
them no idea they have deadly force when
the irs starts auditing all of us you
can bet that i have a stockpile for you
well i've already been yeah already was
got a lot of toe triggers too yeah
that's what i'm gonna need i have a nice
rube goldbergs when the irs comes
knocking and they pull the handle open
goes up through the mantle there's a
duct that dips into water which causes a
pool ball to go down a rod and it pulls
the trigger and my temple will be on the
wall yes
it'll just be
the irs just sends you kurt copeland's
notebook
this is odd elliot smith's dagger
so the bill earmarks 45.6 billion for
what they call enforcement mechanisms
for the irs that's not scary this
includes things like litigation criminal
investigations investigative technology
digital asset monitoring a new fleet of
tax collector cars what
why is there is there an epidemic of tax
collectors not having new enough cars do
they really need to ruin my life by
pulling up in a maybach
[Laughter]
that really sounds very uh accountanty
yes
as in after holding a gun on the cover
of the account than buying another
jackson pollock or the hell it is why
at least they don't rhyme like dr seuss
when they're pulling up in the car
that's the most mob thing i've ever
heard just both in a new catalog hey how
you doing woody irs
be a real shame if something happened
all your stuff yeah i hear you didn't
pay your taxes but i did nah you missed
the loophole though what's it called
it's called my s-class loophole they
don't pay for themselves you gotta pay
for my s-class
that's the loophole the guy's in the
back just like knocking over your family
pictures
oh look at that mess so that's a real
shame ah jeez yeah you got a cute wife
too wow no oh by the way you're not
gonna see her again just bashing your
head against a piano oh you fell look at
that
and he's taking out the wire yeah so
uncle biden says hello
yeah uncle biden wants to know how much
you made on ebay it says here two
hundred dollars just wake up with a
replica aoc head in your bed
[Laughter]
so
way scarier
they say this is going to raise 200
billion in new
revenue oh good
first off can we just get over again
this is really scary they're talking
about litigation they're talking about
new collection methods being able to
monitor your digital assets we just saw
what happened in canada right where they
could freeze your bitcoin
yeah
and more americans are afraid of being
audited then i don't know is it being
audited than death being audited than
cancer i don't know exactly what it is
but it's one of their greatest fears
anyone who's been you were just audited
you know what hell that is it's the
worst you didn't do anything wrong no
you spend all that money for them like
nah right you're fine well yeah and it's
still like and also yeah i just pay this
why but i still didn't do anything wrong
because we said yeah okay
because if you don't pay this we're just
gonna have to restart this whole process
over again yeah you like hell you like
living in it oh yeah we'll take the
check
we're going to send that to the ukraine
for no reason yes
by the way
i noticed you didn't change your flag on
your social media unless you want us
knocking on your door tomorrow you might
consider that also put up a nice black
box on juneteenth [ __ ] don't ever
notice there's no rainbow on your social
media
how do you feel about that you don't
like rainbows what do you think about
this what do you think about that sky
this guy doesn't like rainbows oh that's
[ __ ] weird
well you don't like all the colors yeah
huh
well you don't like leprechauns you know
i'm half irish this is gonna be a
problem
behold it's the pot of gold
all right i'm gonna shoot you so 200
billion they claim is going to come from
new revenue where okay well first off do
you remember when joe biden said this
shortly after taking office again it's
class warfare we're going to reward work
not just wealth
we take the top tax bracket
for the wealthiest one percent of
americans
those making over four hundred thousand
dollars or more
exactly
thirty nine point six percent it was bad
it's only gonna affect three tenths of
one percent of all americans by that
action three tenths of one percent
and the rs is going to crack down on
millionaires and billionaires who cheat
on their taxes
it's estimated to be billions of dollars
my think tanks are left right and center
i'm not looking to punish anybody
but i will not add a tax burden
additional tax burden to the middle
class in this country
they're already paying enough
yeah i agree with that part they're
already paying enough but here's the
problem again with class warfare i've
known some of the most generous people
that i've ever known are wealthy people
some of the most selfish people i've
known are poor people i've also known
some really generous middle class people
yeah uh i will tell you this i've never
known any really really generous poor
people that's just anecdotal
and i've known some selfish rich people
but he says rich people cheating on
their taxes if they're cheating on their
taxes and by the way everyone
technically cheats on their taxes that's
why you have the irs and you just
octupled their funding
what about poor people achieving their
taxes what about the baby mama situation
what about people who specifically uh
under declare income or don't work so
that they can get more ebt card benefits
so they can get more social safety net
benefits that's a cheat as well in other
words everyone can cheat in gaming the
system especially when you consider that
47 of americans don't pay any federal
income taxes so that's my first problem
with what he said there it's they want
you to hate the rich why because they
don't want you to focus on the real
people who are screwing you
them
them even take the worst
take airlines take jeff bezos take tim
people you don't like if they get no
subsidies from the government
if there's no cozy corrupt relationship
guess what they cannot take your money
by force they're incapable of it these
people can simply take your money period
that's the primary problem i have also
it's a lie he said it would only affect
the ultra wealthy well according to the
joint committee on taxation neutral
third party 78 to 90 of the money raised
from under reported income
would come from those making less than
200 000 a year only four to nine percent
would come from those making more than
five hundred thousand four to nine
percent that's not people making
billions upon billions only four to nine
percent would come from those making
more than five hundred thousand and by
the way that also includes small
businesses oh yeah
my c the cpa we have a third-party cpa
who works for us okay as soon as the tax
cuts came into play from donald trump he
hired two new people he ended up hiring
four new people throughout the term of
donald trump
now the revenue from this uh place could
be a few million dollars that's the
gross revenue okay gross revenue let's
say it's five million dollars okay taxes
cut that down to three million dollars
okay payroll just payroll two million
dollars now you have one million dollars
left before the owner of this business
takes any kind of money himself
what are the expenses he could end up
with 250 000 now that's good money you
should be grateful for it but certainly
not the top one percent
and that's most businesses throughout
the united states the businesses will be
burdening this you will be burdening
this and specifically when the
businesses are burning burdening this
they're gonna have two choices okay
they're either gonna have to shutter or
pass the costs on to you yeah
more inflation yeah exactly but
realistically with all of this it's not
i mean you can obviously cheat on your
taxes but either these loopholes that's
willie nelson i know right but these
loopholes either exist or they don't
they're not really loopholes they're
laws that are in place that you can use
and they're not actually illegal right
they're just there so you can call them
loopholes or put this language around
them and have them go after them but
they're in position for people to use
and take advantage of right it doesn't
mean you've done anything wrong well the
problem is usually only people with the
best accountants and the best lawyers
know how to take advantage of them
exactly people like you and me and you
know gerald adults
we don't well no that's true but it it
it doesn't change the fact that he's
going after the wrong people altogether
right right and they always overestimate
right joe biden was saying 3 billion
there i think in in 2019 or 2020 there
was 4 billion dollars in litigation by
the irs they ended up settling for 1.4
billion across all of those cases so way
under half of that money that they said
was going to come in actually came in
and 78 to 90 percent that stat that we
just looked at that's mostly small
businesses people that own a small
business a grocery store or a
convenience store or a small electric
electronic shop something like that
producing that kind of revenue or having
two household income you know wage
earners hundred thousand dollars a year
mom and dad
two hundred thousand dollars coming in
they're getting audited when an audit
happens to a family like that you
literally bend over and take it yeah you
don't have any options right because the
irs is just going to drain
money that you don't even have to try to
fight it 30 or 40 000 like dave said i
was doing it's like mandated divorce
court you know if you end up with let's
say you end up with a spouse we've heard
this a lot and especially from the young
men who watch and someone just wants to
use the court system and extend it and
extend it and extend it and you'll have
divorce cases that go on for three or
four years were you just wasting money
and you end up what you could have
settled with you know using a paralegal
in the first two weeks anyway it's just
the way the system is designed and with
the irs they just say ah
you right
well gerald how much money did you say
it would draw the revenue back back then
it was 1.4 billion on an estimated four
right right yeah so it's well under half
of what they thought when they went to
litigation because most of the time what
they do is they use they bring a case
against somebody and then they settle
out of court for it and so biden's out
there saying oh there's billions of
dollars there i'm like you gave them 80
of those billions i know okay it's gonna
take a while to claw that back and it's
going to come from the middle class and
we just spent an additional 12 to recoup
a possible 1.4
something like that i'm good yeah i
don't that's not great investment and we
need to confer with dr seuss
i don't know a lot about math but it
seems to me your number is higher i hope
to me you enjoy being screwed yeah
this is just eradicating the middle
class though and screwing people over
and allowing the rich to get richer and
the middle class to get poor well this
is mainly allowing those in government
to get richer well 100 yeah that's the
problem that's the problem i have is
people who stand to make a lot of money
who produce nothing i don't have a
problem with the business doing well i
don't have a problem with a business
because i don't have a promise i'm
becoming a billionaire if they're
creating an honest product or service
that i want to use it's a voluntary
exchange of funds this is the problem
with this bill it's huge it's sweeping
it will not reduce inflation it will
increase inflation and it targets you
the average middle-class american
taxpayer something else that's really
interesting i don't i wasn't planning on
talking about this but the stock buyback
they put a law in there where you can't
do stock buybacks but it only takes
effect guess when it only takes effect
when it's in plummet after november
oh
this whole bill is designed to try and
buy your vote it is to say see see look
we stepped in and did something so let's
let's go on here here's another claim
that they are making this is what you
will hear
and by the way you can comment below i
try and frame these in claim and truth
so you can check the references so
hopefully you can have these
conversations with people at your
workplace
um you know if you work from home you're
annoying a house cleaner from ecuador i
don't know
now uh they claim that she's mouthy so
they claim this bill will reduce the
price of prescription drugs by allowing
medicare to negotiate drug prices
the truth
that's one of the few good things in the
bill
allowing medicare to negotiate drug
prices that's actually a good thing
because government bureaucracy basically
for a long time just said uh all right
medicare's gonna pay this uh
pay this fee because that's what we
declare i found out this this weekend
actually i went in to get my foot looked
at okay
the boots the boot yeah turns out by the
way i have an extra bone that's not
supposed to be there it's like tearing
into a ligament they're like i don't
know what this is you're not supposed to
have this bone i'm like aren't you the
doctor shouldn't you
no i don't know so
you got a lot of stuff going yeah you
have a lot of weird stuff that's what
they say
they bring in another doctor goes hmm
is that the diagnosis hmm
missing from somewhere else should it be
somewhere else thanks dr latka no
he brings in the caveman right before
humans go
i think it's similar to that
but uh maybe you're a mutant superpower
i found out when i was doing cash only
they said uh by the way and if you need
to get a boot before you leave if you
want to do that you don't have to go
through the prices and stuff oh wait you
paid cash it's free it's included
i said wait how much would it have been
if it was a few hundred dollars so it
would have been more yeah if i went
through insurance it's free
my boot is a party favor
only if you pay cash
so that's the problem with big
absolutely big bureaucracy big you know
these big red tape or it's designed to
confuse people so it's a good thing it's
a good thing for medicare to be able to
negotiate prices
but here's the problem
and this is the politics at play and
this is i will say this this is evil
this is evil because when you understand
the context you will understand that
they couldn't let president trump have a
win so they deliberately screwed you
they deliberately harmed you
so they could take this action and claim
credit let me explain july 2020 uh
president trump then president trump
signed multiple executive orders aimed
at lowering drug prices and what
included allowing importing drugs from
canada
basing the cost of u.s drugs off of
their price internationally and capped
copay and insulin at 35 dollars monthly
now let me explain to you why this is
such an effective way okay the united
states and i understand what you're
saying um as far as big pharma it is a
problem we pay a lot more than other
countries pay for drugs for example
right now you can order drugs from
canada they're far cheaper the reason
for that is because the government
subsidizes them so let's say you come up
i don't know with some new
anti-inflammatory anti-depressant okay
in canada it costs a hundred dollars in
the united states it costs you six
hundred dollars the drug companies would
create their product and what they would
invest into r d their business model was
predicated on charging a certain price
abroad while that subsidization would be
burdened by the americans
that's the problem was deliberately
designed to say well we'll get money
from these governments and in the united
states we'll charge the average consumer
more so when donald trump said you're
going to charge americans
what is charged in other countries that
forces them to not just rely on
government money and the american
taxpayer the american middle class it
was a very
effective
uh mode of strategy that he used okay
and the cap on insulin at 35 monthly
kind of a big topic right now yeah
little bits how let me ask you this
tell your friend just do this just do
this today if you do nothing else go out
comment below let me know what they say
tell people when they discuss this you
know that president trump capped the
copan insulin at 35 a month right
it's trending all over twitter or
instagram just see if they know it okay
so donald trump signed those executive
orders
then february 2021 biden decided to end
those executive orders that were aimed
at lowering drug prices so that now in
this bill he can claim look i'm allowing
medicare to negotiate drug prices but
these there are policies that already
existed to lower the costs of drugs it
was one of the first things that former
vice president biden did he came into
office he ended those so he could show
you the skyrocketing costs of drugs
and then take credit
for lowering them in a less effective
way yes medicare should be able to
negotiate drug prices
donald trump made sure that drug prices
were more for the first time in modern
american history remember that for the
first time the average price of
pharmaceuticals went down that was a big
deal then they started going back up so
that biden can come in and here he comes
to save the day you know it's kind of
funny here uh six they get to negotiate
the prices of six drugs yes in a couple
of years and a few years after that
closer to 2030 they get to negotiate the
price of i think an additional 12. right
it's the stupidest thing i've ever heard
it's like at some point we'll negotiate
but you can only do six drugs why but at
least negotiate all of the prices if
that's if that's your thing at least 272
million in this bill is going to
windmill teepees so that's a good thing
yeah so uh look when we can talk
you know landlord if this show we're
playing on an airplane i'd walk out oh
my
god yeah i sure hope dave goes back to
doing what he used to do you mean
showing luggage no i mean drinking
himself to death at least then we'd have
a laugh
that's just mean it's rude i don't know
why we still installed that balcony all
right hey before we get into our next
story we actually have a developing
situation that i thought would be
interesting we talked about the only
fans like that mole on your thumb uh
martha bueno we're actually trying right
now to see if we can get her on skype
for the second hour of the show i'm just
gonna pass over that like it didn't
happen
yeah i know that's how you treat all of
your medical anomalies if we can get her
i think i think it's been confirmed that
we can't i'm trying to get a time that
she's going to be able to come on uh so
not just a story about martha bueno but
martha bueno martha buenanto
no idea i've never seen it
all right
so let me know if she doesn't want to
come on all right we'll let you it might
be best to do that on mug club because
we don't know what's going to happen on
youtube
let's uh go on to uh everyone's favorite
area of the globe
i can say [ __ ] now palestine there
you go so um
this is what has been going on uh you
know what before let's make sure this
segment what's really important is not
so much that you know palestine and
palestine
uh
my problem is with the fact checkers we
need to fact check the fact checkers
yeah tweet check fact trump trump fact
check tweet fact check
news
okay
so this is tragic obviously and i'm
going to show you a clip which is sad to
watch but it's it's also um
untruthful there's been a conflict going
on in gaza i believe for three days and
uh 44 people have died including
children that's a tragedy any way you
slice it
we don't need to compound it by lying
about it and of course those in big tech
don't actually uh consistently apply
their rules so here's a video uh
misinforming you
from al jazeera
[Music]
for those listening on audio it says
against gaza's islamic jihad group
children are amongst the dozens of
victims
six children have been killed in the
first 72 hours of attacks by israel
israel killed more than 60 gazan
children in 2021 okay so that's what the
video says horrific want to make sure
that we understand two separate things
here now we need to fact check something
turns out that rocket was actually a
failed launch
by islamic jihadist militants from
palestine
whoops
so
they claim that it's israel yeah this is
released everywhere al jazeera and i'll
get to the tweets from all these
politicians those people who reset
represent you who are lowering inflation
uh
running with a story that is verifiably
untrue and by the way something like
this when you're verifiably and
repeatedly um in in a chronic way
misreporting a conflict more people die
that's important to note
that's the role of journalism hopefully
is to be accurate so that people can
make better decisions moving forward uh
the idf uploaded a video showing the
failed missile that was launched from
palestine
there you go
you see them
missiles going out
and the missile doesn't quite make it
you can see the trajectory right now
and all the rest of them yeah the rest
of them do so you can see
i know some of you are saying hey uh
idea if i don't trust them okay i
understand what you're saying
you can't say that and then trust al
jazeera whoever and i understand that we
we fund israel too much i understand
that a relationship there is too cozy i
i think that a deal that would be
appropriate would be don't send funding
to any of those countries don't send any
funding to iran don't send funding to
any country who want to wipe israel off
the face of the map and then we wouldn't
need to be intertwined with that we
could still have a friendly relationship
with israel so i understand that
that's a separate point from the fact
that israel actually builds an iron dome
israel protects their citizens israel
sounds alarmed so that their children
can get to safe places and hamas or
these other terrorist groups in
palestine launch their missiles their
rockets from
churches they launch them from mosques
they launch them from grade schools yeah
they use their citizens as shields
whereas israel tries to shield their
citizens for all of their flaws across
the board now here's something else
that's pretty important uh al-jazeera
they tweeted out israeli attacks on gaza
have killed 29 people including six
children and four women in the besieged
palestinian enclave rashida tulabe
from good old michigan we know her well
dave
a wonderful woman tweeted out the lives
of the palestinian people are not
disposable no one's saying they are the
fact that our country continues to
ignore and fund the aggressive violence
and killing of palestinian lives you
mean the palestinian forces especially
children just enables more death it's
not okay to keep looking away it's
actually sickening well you know what
else it's not okay to actually
lie
no now let's take a look at another look
at those tweets from al jazeera please
tell the palestinians to stop killing
their children that's a that would be a
good start yeah but their tweets are
still up
here is the point according to twitter's
crisis misinformation policy
they should be tagged with a warning if
they include quote false allegations
regarding use of force incursions on
territorial sovereignty or around the
use of weapons neither of these tweets
or countless similar ones have the
warning however tweets like this let me
read it for you a pressing question why
are they trying so hard to get every
single person on the planet vaccinated
with the ineffective vaccine bring that
up overlay d4
that has a misinformation label
do you have overlay d4 yeah i got to get
it yeah yeah so people saying why are
they trying so hard to get every single
person on the planet vaccinated with an
ineffective vaccine that's labeled as
misleading
and by the way this is i believe in the
context of joe biden getting covered for
the 18th time and maybe with the blood
type vaccinations allegedly
allegedly solid three at least four
maybe who knows you know what so i mean
you said this it's not okay to lie and
it's not okay to put this kind of
information out and not have people go
wait a minute wait a minute this this
isn't true because here's what's gonna
happen that's gonna get rolled into a
promotional recruiting video right for
this group and what's gonna happen is
some kid out there is gonna be like fine
this has happened in my neighborhood i'm
done i've had enough of israel shooting
and killing us i'm gonna strap on a vest
i'm gonna go fire a gun i'm gonna throw
rocks i'm gonna fire a rocket into this
and i'm gonna take to the streets to
fight that's exactly what's gonna happen
and guess what more deaths probably that
person killing themselves in the process
the reason i wanted to cover this is i
can't think of a more especially in the
wake of what happened with alex jones
and wherever you line up you can
understand that look when there's
something happening in the mainstream
press there's an event that obviously uh
is is an international
news story like sandy hook and people
are presenting opinions which can be
wrong yeah
in the wake of that i can't think of a
more clear-cut example of something that
is verifiably false uh rashida clay
verifiably false i don't know if she's
retracted it but certainly from al
jazeera actual propaganda yeah
when would it be more appropriate to
simply label something misleading what
it involves the deaths of dozens of
children
this is how you know they're not looking
out for you it's not about truth it's
about ensuring that people in power can
control what you read can control what
you know the same thing with the irs
it's not about reducing inflation it's
about adding 80 billion dollars to a
four billion dollar agency so that they
can litigate and prosecute and audit you
it's not the standard isn't does this
country have laws
it's are the laws applied equally
leftist you know that because you see
they're not applied equally to
minorities okay
i'm not even going to get into that
right now it's the same thing with these
big tech platforms it's not do they have
rules
it's are they applied equally and
applying it to something that we say
about kovit quoting the cdc but not
applying it to al jazeera
an organization funded
known by a known foreign caliphate lying
about the deaths of children hey they
say sandy hook they lied about the
deaths of children
even then you can get into gray
territory there wasn't lying saying that
these children didn't die i was talking
about the media being
inconsistent wherever you line up and i
think it was a big misstep i think it
was wrong i always try and wait until
the information comes in but in this
case they are lying about the deaths of
children yeah they're lying about the
deaths of children it's are the rules
are the laws applied equally if they are
not you are not living in a free society
we also have an american politician
caring more about something going on
overseas than she's ever cared about
anything going on oh yeah oh no she
supported increasing the irs oh right
that's true yeah
it's about being subservient and giving
up all your money working hard for
something that's constantly being taken
away from you and completely giving the
power over to people that don't deserve
it it's about just making the government
more powerful yep
why
i just don't understand the purpose of
all this and how people are blind to it
i don't understand how people can keep
supporting this and thinking that it's a
benefit to you it's a denial of human
nature yeah it's a denial of god it's a
denial of anything there's no morality
to it anymore well i think it comes down
to uh and i've talked about this i think
with dennis pragers do you believe that
people are inherently good or do you
believe that they're inherently flawed i
believe that people are inherently
sinful inherently selfish just look at
kids uh and if you believe that you say
okay what's the most effective system of
checks and balances that's the
constitution that's freedom that's a
representative republic where we say we
know that people
if left to make their own decisions some
will make good ones some will make bad
ones but if you believe that
my side is inherently virtuous my side
is inherently good meaning the democrats
rashida toled al jazeera i repeat myself
then of course they should have power we
should consolidate power to these people
do you know who you want as president do
you know who you want and for as much
crap as people give rand paul
you know rand paul basically doesn't
even want the job that's what he's like
i don't want my i vote no because i
shouldn't be able to do that people like
oh you're not doing anything that's what
you want you want someone who basically
does nothing
it's better to have someone who does
nothing than increases the size of their
office their government their paycheck
every single year because they don't
have to do anything to earn it other
than vote present
so if you believe that human beings are
inherently good but only on one side
then you want that power centralized
well you can also take that power though
and the only way you get it is by
hurting other people and you have no
problem doing that which takes kind of a
sociopath sort of a logic yeah
politicians yeah well yeah absolutely do
me a favor please point in history to
the group of people that you think have
been inherently good that we can go oh
we ought to model ourselves off of them
genghis khan never oh great guy but what
happens is though what is the end game
for this because when you look at it
let's say for example somebody wanted to
have power over people say a slave
master
eventually you piss those people off to
the point where they revolt right people
will behead the king so no matter how
hard you keep pushing the the people and
you keep doing this there will be a
revolt eventually and i don't mean to be
this like dramatic no there will be but
the reality is is you cannot keep doing
this to people you cannot keep screwing
them over forcing them to do things they
don't want to
taking all their money
going after their children like it's
getting to the point and not allowing
them to access information that's
absolutely yeah let's see this is why
they want you to take away their speech
though yeah and that's what happened
over the weekend that's why they want
you to go oh they say if you're going to
revolt revolt against these uh wealthy
people who are the wealthy uh the
business owners it's the business these
are the people you want to go after not
the politicians who have suckled the
government the public teat for 58 years
not people whose stock and investment
portfolios have grown 3 000
since they've been serving the public
they want you
to hate the rich that's why i say i
don't hate big business i don't hate
small business i hate bad business i
support good business i don't care if
you're rich i don't care if you're poor
i don't care if you're left i don't care
just don't lie to me and i have we need
to make sure
and if i serve no other purpose than to
draw a very important line for you it's
because of your own selfish nature it's
very easy to appeal to it and to appeal
to covetousness dickens talked about
this right it's easy
to get people to covet i don't want you
to covet what your neighbor has
i want you to make sure
that those in power can't legislate
their own covetousness
that's the issue not rich versus poor
not white versus black it's people in
power with ill-gotten gain speaking of
which i think we need to move on here to
this is uh this is an issue near and
dear to my heart it is yes
and it's it's common sense car control
that we need now so
i know what you're thinking
stephen you're more libertarian not on
this
[Laughter]
so uh in uh
2020
there are 19 000 approximately a firearm
deaths not including suicides okay
42 000 people died in motor vehicle
crashes
in 2021 according to the national
highway traffic safety administration
there is an epidemic in the u.s and it's
called random car violence
it's out of control and again going back
to those in power uh
i don't know if it's conspiracy but i
think it goes from the top down because
there's a disproportionate number of our
representatives who are engaged in these
acts of violence where i think it's
almost deliberate
but uh
let me show to you why first i'm calling
for common sense car control
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i can leave it there i've made my point
but i have some more information for you
so well those are just nancy pelosi's
husband's dash cam
he's tried a lot yeah he has to get out
of this progressive is not going to
lower that insurance though
i'm surprised i'm surprised that he
bought christine
now
there are more than two times the number
of firearm deaths in this country from
vehicles okay
2021 there was a 10.5 percent increase
over 2020 a lot
that marked a 16-year high not seen
since 2005. wow
over 7 400 of those were pedestrians
between 2018 2020 the percentage of
fatalities among children doubled from
5.8 to 11.9 percent while legislation
went up to make vehicles more safe and
inevitably it doesn't always really
necessarily make them more safe but
here's what really gets me
politicians
are disproportionately and intimately
involved
with these acts of violence
and that is why they refuse to act on it
that's why you would think they would do
something they want to ban the ar-15
which is responsible for like
statistically no deaths in comparison
what about the ford focus
that it's a little too close to home for
people like
paul pelosi
just pled not guilty in relation to dui
charges
he wrecked his car with a blood alcohol
level of over
.08
i don't know if you guys saw the
prosecutor's gonna be there it's a joke
um
even former vice president this is why
they don't want to d they don't want
common sense
car control now and you can comment
below if you want common sense car
control it's common sense and it's
control of cars
sounds good
it all adds up it all adds up perfectly
i love it yeah
take this seriously it's going to be a
fun show
former vice president uh joe biden even
made light
why would he do this
of duis while on the campaign trail in
2020
you're fired if in fact you do that you
only arrest for the purpose of dealing
with a felony that's committed and i
don't count drunk driving as a felony
what how about drunk presidenting
[Laughter]
drunk speaker of the housing you know
people enjoy you pointing a finger at
them yeah exactly like harrison ford
that dui was supposed to be for my wife
harrison that doesn't make any sense at
all i should be in a museum
where's my earring yes you want to land
a plane on a non-runway again yeah so
you know who's most happy about uh
uh former vice president biden's
position there beto o'rourke yeah again
while we're talking about duis
he's still a douche
doesn't he look way cooler yeah he does
there
he looks a little compared to now
that would totally be a douche no he's a
douche but he's still a better douche
there yeah he looks like one of the lost
boys yeah
they lost he doesn't need a vampire
um yes if he doesn't drink blood he
drinks another fluid yeah exactly oh
what oh i didn't say it
break fluid that's why he crashed
who can forget ted kennedy uh you know
infamously and allegedly killed and by
allegedly i mean absolutely killed 28
year old mary joker pecky after sending
his vehicle off the uh
the dyke bridge which is funny on chap
acquittal island
uh so we have beto we have pelosi we
have elephants ted kennedy and biden
kennedy coming back with fish in his
pants i i don't know where the car is
the mystery going out of his pockets
like one of those things the ambulance
right no i called my father to see what
the hell to do yeah i did put on this
fake neck brace though
i tried to uh save her i got to shore
and i yelled
yeah
i yelled i'm going to bed here
night night nothing is it just on uh
going to bed
that's all
you know she probably tried reaching for
him and he was like
stop it i'll be back in a tool not to
cut the seat belt with the double knot
doing scout crafts
she's kicking her on his way out
blow torching the door
like when they go in for artifacts and
underwater shipwrecks
he's using his seat as a flotation
device for when this happens yes
[Laughter]
just walking around with a seat on his
back
so here's the thing this might be a
conspiracy but i don't think they want
common sense car reform why because when
we talk about the top political donors
of all time you guys need to look at
unions uh the united auto workers
union and their political donations i
don't know if you know this in 2022 1.3
million went to democratic candidates
that's 99.9 percent
of the unions oh
yeah total contract i bet they took a
vote and asked their workers who they
would like them to spend that money on
the dues that are forcibly removed from
their paychecks right yeah yeah exactly
no it's not a racket
and this is why i think that there is uh
no legislation making it possible to sue
manufacturers when someone wields one of
these death machines against somebody
else when you have a company like
remington having to pay for sandy hook i
just want to know
when good old hyundai's on the hook
because beta o'rourke mows down an
entire fleet of uh
people outside of the cafe or ford
or ford used a lot gm
and this is global maserati this
happened in france a lot of philadelphia
i'm sure it was a nissan cube yes
dressed like one of the gerbils in those
commercials the kia cause he finds them
cute
yeah i'm sure that's where you find him
in beta aurora yes
no no it's the nissan richard gere so my
point is this
you're focusing on the wrong issue here
we're focusing not only on on on
firearms which is a very very small
percentage of deaths that uh occur
annually in this country but also
focusing on rifles that make up even
fewer of those deaths as it relates to
firearm homicides it's not even close as
it relates to motor vehicles and people
say yeah well i need a license to
purchase to drive a car why don't you
need one to use a firearm well because
one is an enshrined constitutional right
and it's also not working
lots of people are dying
primarily 99 and you don't need to check
the references at lower credit.com for
this one i'm going by wrote 99.8 percent
of people who are killed in vehicular
homicides uh are by current democratic
representatives we're going to go to mug
club i believe that we have we do
we're going to have miss bueno miss
buenos aires for those of you you know
okay so before by the way hit the share
button right now if you're watching
before we go to a piss off youtube hit
the share button that helps with the
show smash the like button
um and let me just roll this clip before
we have her on the show
uh
martha bueno is her name deliberate
libertarian candidate for miami-dade uh
miami-dade commissioner and uh she is
using only fans to raise campaign funds
let's roll the clip and then we'll go to
muk club
[Music]
democracy
yeah
let's get some of that democracy going
kevin
gonna be some damn good democracy
i think there's some pre-democracy
[Music]
yeah
youtube we about to talk with martha
bueno youtube piss off
[Music]
you